it was one of the great hopes
against the coronavirus the vaccine
from the german pharmaceutical company
curevag was expected
to be among the first to hit the market
in june
came the bitter disappointment europe's
regulator did not approve the vaccine
after clinical studies showed it was
less than 50 percent effective
this also came as a big disappointment
for the german government
which last year bought a stake in the
company
worth around 300 million euros
[Music]
welcome to your covent 19 special i'm
chris colbert in berlin
high expectations low results curavax
covet 19 jab
did not turn out what many had hoped it
would be
that's despite using the same messenger
rna technology as rivals moderna
and biontech fisa qrvec aimed to produce
its vaccine primarily for developing
countries
as it can be stored more easily than
other products and despite disappointing
trial results
the company is sticking to the plan
efren hernandez has got used to taking
his temperature
and recording the results in an app
based in mexico city
he's been part of german company
curevac's covid19 vaccine trial
since january
the fact that the german government bill
gates
and tesla all supported curabac
convinced me that it was a safe bet
but disappointing news was to come in
june when it emerged that kyravac's jab
had an efficacy rate of only 48 percent
the reality is more complicated to me
kiravax 48 effectiveness doesn't seem
bad
compared to other vaccines like pfizers
which in the end have a real-life
effectiveness of between
49 and 64 percent
study took place when all the new
variants were circulating
hernandez is one of more than 30 000
people in latin america who signed up to
take part in the kurvak trial
uncertainty among test subjects is rife
many aren't sure whether or not they
have protection
the vaccination drive overall in mexico
has got off to a sluggish start
according to the world health
organization less than a fifth of the
country's population has been fully
vaccinated
one major factor is cost curevac says it
is able to produce its vaccine more
cheaply than biontech pfizer
and curevac's jab has also been shown to
offer protection
against serious illness
i think it will be a tool in the fight
against covid 19 in latin american
countries
in patients aged 18 to 60 in mexico
the efficacy for avoiding severe illness
as well as hospitalization
intensive care and death was higher than
80 percent
the vaccine performs better against
alpha
and delta alpha
delta but qrvak's jab has still not been
given the green light
authorities in mexico city say the
company has not yet applied for approval
there
at the company's headquarters in the
german city of tubingen
managers are hoping to get approval from
the european medicines agency
but no one was prepared to offer any
details about the process
meanwhile the german government has
ruled out stepping
in
i don't see any need to assess this
ourselves because i think we're in good
hands with the european medicines agency
also no matter what vaccines we have we
have committed to give the extra to
african and latin american countries
and for the moment we've put that number
at 30 million jabs
but it could be more
in the meantime efren hernandez will
continue to pass on his temperature
readings to the researchers
to this day he doesn't know whether he's
received the vaccine
or a placebo the head of kurovac said
the low efficacy
was a result of delayed start of testing
when many more variants were circulating
than during competitors trials i asked
peter kremzner
director of the institute for tropical
medicine
at to begin university hospital and head
of the curavac trial here in germany
if he agreed this may be one explanation
but certainly
for me not the most important one
for me it is rather the dose we were
stuck to
a maximum of 12 microgram which came out
in the phase one trial when we judged
the
safety and tolerability and
immunogenicity of the vaccine and we
were not able to
those higher than 12 microgram per shot
because of yeah too much
of intolerability
above that so for me it was the dose and
the competitors could those three to ten
times higher
and for me this is the main explanation
does that have to do with something that
the uh financial times
reported which would be uh that
curvature was reluctant to work with
modified messenger rna because it would
have to buy the patents for it
unlike biontec and moderna which did
just that
well that is a likely explanation
and that is the main difference
otherwise the sequence
of the s antigen is the same
but the difference is that modern and
biontech have modified
the uracil to pseudo-uridine and
that makes a difference obviously in
tolerability
and then one can dose higher and get
better immunogenicity and thereby
obviously better efficacy
the kirvak vaccine can be stored
at higher temperatures which makes
countries and warmer regions of the
world
a suitable market those often are poorer
countries too
now is it justifiable sending a vaccine
to these countries
that works less well than others
well that may be something which is
interesting
and certainly others are also working on
this as well as curework to the best of
my knowledge and
until very recently we have stored and
we've
urged to store the vaccine of cure work
at minus 80 degrees celsius and only for
the day of vaccination we were allowed
to thaw it and store it
in the fridge between two and eight
degrees celsius
for a few hours and then discard the
rest
after that so these things are
possible and i guess the mrna
vaccines from the data i know
are all storable at even high
temperatures
even room temperatures even tropical
temperatures but these
stability tests have to be performed and
the regulators need to agree that this
is a possibility
until now i am not aware of anything
like this
for kuvak or for other companies
should the current vaccine be approved
could it be used as a booster shot for a
possible
third inoculation for example here in
europe
that is certainly a possibility for all
those
vaccines which are under development
under clinical development and didn't
get yet
an approval one needs to consider
whether
a booster vaccination is the best
approach
because most of the other
people at least in europe are now
already vaccinated
at least once and the booster
will come up at some time and this is
something
where we are looking into that every
everybody is looking into that
all right peter kremzner he is the
director of the institute for
tropical medicine in tubingen and head
of the
german kurovac trial thanks for being on
the program peter
thank you
staying on the topic of vaccines here is
dw's
science correspondent derek williams
are the current vaccines causing
selective variants to search
this is another of those internet rumors
that's gained some traction
in the last few weeks because somehow it
sounds
like it might be kind of plausible but
it actually isn't and
to explain why i have to go over
some of the basics again um all viruses
evolve randomly over time as they
replicate
and a minuscule number of those
mutations will prove
advantageous let's say that one of them
makes a mutant
a lot more transmissible in humans voila
a potentially dangerous new variant
over time that variance offspring
could start to supplant earlier versions
of the virus simply because the variance
spreads
to more unprotected people in a
population
within a shorter period of time because
it's more transmissible
so when you start to look for that
variance specifically
in that population you see increasing
numbers of people
getting it a surge but that's an effect
that can be traced back to the variant's
ability to spread faster in people
with no immunity not something that's
caused by or or driven by
vaccines what vaccines do is turn
unprotected people into protected people
with immune systems
that are quickly able to shut down any
subsequent
infections with sars kobe 2 whether
that infection would have been with a
fast spreading variant or
or a slower spreading one in other words
they keep us from turning into virus
factories where the pathogen
can replicate a lot and and the less the
virus replicates
the fewer chances it has to mutate
so in the long run vaccines will
actually help prevent other potentially
dangerous
new variants from arising by slowing
and stopping the spread of sars kobe 2
and
drastically reducing the number of times
that it's able to make copies of itself
[Music]